welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is basha Koosh an assistant professor of
sociology at Wesleyan University she's
here at Yale as a visiting faculty
fellow at the Council on Middle East
Studies at the Macmillan Center her
research interests include inequality
finance and society regulatory politics
and economic crises and reforms she also
writes about Turkish political economy
today we'll talk with Professor cush
about her work on financialization
credit and income inequality
welcome professor cush hi thank you for
everything let's start with income
inequality what kind of work have you
done around that topic sure my work
attempts to understand the ways in which
financialization of advanced economies
over the past few decades mattered for
income inequality and for the larger
politics of inequality before going into
further detail it might be helpful to
give a bit of perspective about the
recent trends on income inequality sure
over the past few decades income
inequality has been on the rise in most
OECD nations in many of these nations
folks in the top 10% and 1% had
benefited greatly from economic growth
than they've been taking the lion's
share of total income for folks at the
lower end of income distribution is a
different story right a recent OECD
report for instance shows that 40% of
the population at the lower end of the
income distribution benefited very
little from economic growth if at all in
some nations actually this group has
seen their incomes fall in real terms I
think this is why we are seeing so much
public concern over growing income
inequality especially since the 2008
economic crisis and I think this is why
this
has been very silly into the recent
presidential campaigns exactly
everyone's talking about that 1%
absolutely so to come back to your
question I'm very interested in
understanding the causes of rising
income inequality but I also am very
interested in understanding why
governments and individuals respond to
it the way they do and in various papers
are written in in the past few years
I've been trying to make the case that
in order to engage with the contemporary
politics of inequality in order to make
sense of both the rising income
inequality and governments response to
it you really have to put that put it in
the context of this significant
structural transformation that has taken
place in advanced economies and and that
is financialization okay and what do you
mean by that term sure so we're talking
about the growing size and presence of
financial institutions financial
transaction and activities in the
overall economy but also in the everyday
life of citizens let me be a bit more
specific than that okay so the size of
the financial sector has been increasing
in in advanced nations over the past few
decades in the United States since the
early 1980s there has been a steady
shift from manufacturing towards finance
oriented activities for instance
sociologists credit repair shows us that
the share of the financial sector in
total corporate profits was around 10-15
percent in the 1950s and 60s in the
1980s it has increased it had increased
to 20 percent by the end of the 1990s it
was over 40 percent the contribution of
the financial sector to GDP more than
doubled from the early 1980s to
mid-2000s so that's one aspect of it but
that's not all in the same period we
also saw that non-financial corporations
began to rely on financial sector and
financial investments as as their source
of income and profit we saw even
consensual industrial
like General Electric set up and manage
banking operations by 2001 for instance
that that's the year when Jack Welch is
standing around it at a General Electric
geez G was making more than half of its
revenue and more than one-third of its
profits from the finance operations and
these things were happening another
important development that took place
was that a new corporate governance
style emerged in the United States
finance oriented managers began to
manage major corporations and
financialization rewarded them by
increasing their stock prices and
increasing the stock prices actually
became their primary motive rather than
focusing on long term market share
productivity innovation they really
began to pay a lot of attention to
short-term financial payoffs so that was
another sort of important part of the
developments that we sort of described
under the topic of financialization and
finally finance penetrated into the
everyday life of citizens right citizens
began to span in financial markets
invest in - financial markets they began
to borrow from financial markets they
actually became really reliant on
financial markets for their
socio-economic stability so for instance
the share of stocks in the total for the
profits of American households more than
doubled from the early 1980s to to the
end of the 1990s again from the early
1990s these are numbers that I can
remember from the top of my mind upon
till the crisis in that sort of two
decades of period Americans use of
credit increased tremendously so these
are the transformations that we're
talking about when we talk about
financialization and now there is really
interesting work looking at the ways in
which these sort of mechanisms these
these developments mattered for income
inequality so for instance as I said the
size of the financial sector expanded
right
it's happened at the expense of the
non-financial sector the fruit is the
profitability of the non-financial
sector
declined there is increasing consensus
among scholars that it impacted the
paychecks of the many working-class and
middle-class folks operating in those
non-financial sectors similarly as this
new corporate governance style emerged
CEOs running these companies found
incentive to cut labor costs and they
were rewarded when they banned it when
they made those hard decisions another
mechanism set seems to have mattered a
lot is that we find a financial asset
ownership is really concentrated at the
top of the wealth distribution and as we
know income from capital is higher for
larger investments so individuals high
income high net-worth individuals were
able to gain a lot of income from their
capital through investing in financial
markets and that capital did not remain
subject to the form of taxation that
other forms of income are typically
subject to another mechanism that that
seems to have mattered is that
governments as they were trying to and
definitely the United States promote the
growth of the financial sector you know
embrace certain policies and most
importantly of which was keeping the
inflationary pressures at bay and this
also meant that you know they would
sometimes embrace austerity logic which
would thank her they're sort of
possibility to to redistribute and so
there's a lot of work right now that
shows us that financialization mattered
in in that sense for income inequality
my own work using cross national data
over time data has also shown it also
shows that finance exerted upward
pressure on income inequality in
advanced countries during the past few
decades what countries are you looking
at I've been looking there it's always
feeding nations yeah and so yes so we
know that financialization mattered
for income inequality but it's not all
of it
it also mattered for the larger politics
of inequality and I think in that sense
we also have to pay a lot of attention
to credit markets and households
increasing use of credit mmm-hmm okay so
is there a connection between income
inequality and credit absolutely as part
of my research has been trying to
basically sort of explore that that
linkage so let me step back and first of
all say that I think it's one of the
most important developments of the past
few decades households including
increasing use of credit in the United
States credit has been a mainstay of
American middle-class life since the end
of the Second World War if not earlier
but even then if you look at the past
few decades the role of credit in
society has become more prominent and
the data shows us that income inequality
and increase in credit use they've been
moving in tandem with each other in the
United States now increasing credit use
is not necessarily an American story it
has been happening in other advanced
nations as well to the extent that it's
happening in this country it's very
prominent in the United States very
prominent in the United Kingdom and in
the United States it was much higher
compared to other European nations to
begin with but still it's much higher
but European nations have begun to catch
up as well they're also there's there's
a substantial increase so in my work
what I'm trying to say is that credit
matters a lot for inequality and for
politics of inequality it's a very
powerful political tool and and impact
on equality can be observed in several
ways
first of all credit allows individuals
to consume a wide array of services and
and and products that they might may not
be able to consume otherwise right if
they state within their means right
this might affect this content this
might decrease it this contact that they
might be having with their actual level
of income and purchasing power it
affects the way
people understand the structure of
inequality in society and their place in
it right so this is this is a really
important thing it blurs class
differences it makes it harder to infer
to distinguish it makes it harder to
infer who has it who else nots right to
distinguish between the haves and
have-nots of this world so that's one
really important impact of credits in
terms of sort of politics of inequality
but it also credit use also I believe
affected the ways in which governments
began to respond to inequality in the
post-war era governments routinely used
tools of social policy to intervene and
sort of to create to to to deal with
social risks and to generate economic
prosperity like what so social spending
right to create jobs when sort of to to
make transfer payments when the gap
between the rich and poor got to whites
to sort of narrow to narrow that gap in
the past few decades what we see is
retrenchment of government into
intervention in these areas but at the
same time with the expansion of credit
markets right in the past governments in
order to be able to make intervention in
these areas they would suspend in order
to spend they would sometimes take on
that right private public domestic
foreign in the recent area in their in
the recent era in the past few decades
we see citizens taking on debt right to
enhance their lifestyles to be able to
buy that nice house or simply to make
ends meet so what is happening is then
sort of shift from socialization of risk
to privatization of risk what we see is
that as financial citizenship has taken
hold
social citizenship has been undermined a
little bit so in two papers that I that
I wrote I found that credit access
actually makes it possible for
governments to sort of avoid urgency of
dealing with increasing income
inequality and it also makes it makes
citizens in our city nations to worry
less about inequality and and to be
somewhat less supportive of of
redistributive policies but do you think
that in terms of the population using
the credit because they basically are
not making enough money it gets to a
certain point where you're maxed out so
then do the governments then have to
reevaluate what they've done this is a
great question and I thought I would
come to that towards the end of our
conversation absolutely this is a very
tricky politics because what credit does
is it might fill that gap between your
income and your consumption Inspirations
right so it month it might enhance your
living standard today but in the long
run it might actually make you very
vulnerable to various macroeconomic
shocks right it might increase
heightened socioeconomic vulnerabilities
so in the context of the United States
this was sort of talked about as the
hidden crises of the American
middle-class and it is it is a tricky
politics and and yes it's not
sustainable and if anything one of the
things that the 2008 economic crisis has
shown us is that it's not sustainable
and governments have to be very careful
in terms of who uses credit with what
terms and so on and so forth now I know
you're also very interested in what's
going on in Turkey so why don't you you
know elaborate on what you're doing
there in terms of how your research
speaks to the political economy of
Turkey absolutely so this year I'm a
fellow it's a council for Middle East
Studies at Yale and I wrote a paper
factor coming out in a few weeks in the
Middle East report which is looking at
the development of financial citizenship
credit markets and sort of electoral
politics in Turkey so in Turkey also
during the past few decades we saw a
sort of a reformulation of this is the
relationship between
the state banks credit markets and
citizens until the 1980s Turkey was very
much a state oriented economy with a
large public sector some sort of a mixed
economy in the 1980s the cognitive
liberalisation policy started and an
important part of the this economic
liberalisation policies was financial
liberalization in about two decades the
number of banks doubles we saw a lot of
new sort of private banks we saw foreign
bank entry into the system and many of
these changes however very similar to
other transition economies happens very
quickly and in the absence of a rigorous
regulatory framework so in the 1990s the
country was shaken by a series of
economic crises okay so the Justice and
Development Party led by Iran came to
power in 2002 after this sort of a
decade-long
economic turbulence and instability
right and during the first term of the
Justice and Development Party and the
second term is well economic growth a
grew quite fast and in this context of
economic growth and rising consumption
credit use began to increase as well
it's important to understand that
Turkish context is very different from
the American context credit where credit
use was not never never had to be a
mainstay of middle-class life if
families found themselves in hardships
they would go gets money from their
relatives their kin they would sometimes
go to stores and purchase goods on
installment credit but credit markets
the baby seat on the understand in the
United States they didn't really exist
starting from the early 2000s we see a
substantial growth of credit use by
Turkish our souls and the mechanisms
that I've been describing they were at
they being at play in the Turkish
context as well we saw sort of people
experiencing a boost in their purchasing
power being able to produce
assume a wide array of services and
products we saw again class boundaries
getting blurred so these are important
in terms of politics of Unicode in terms
of people's understanding of class and
these developments also test the
existing level of societal welfare in a
very positive light and I think in
looking at the recent political
developments of Turkey it's important to
identify this dimension as well one of
the major questions about Turkish
politics recently has been why has
Justice and Development Party being so
successful since 2002 the party has
emerged victorious from every election
pretty much it has entered right and why
is that the case so there are several
arguments about that and one of them is
well economic growths right another
argument is well social welfare
provision there have been some good
things about that especially in the
healthcare area but also development of
sorts and informal networks sort of
basic goods provision through you know
sort of neighborhood communities and so
on and so forth but my argument this
paper is financialization expansion of
credit markets and the sort of emergence
of credit based welfare is another
factor that I think have country that
has contributed to the success of this
political party and we have to talk
about it but again just like you pointed
out this is a tricky politics and and
and Turkish hassles are I think becoming
increasingly vulnerable and this is
something to think about okay so do you
think is the income the inequality of
income
comparable to what it is in the United
States among OECD countries inequality
in Turkey I think it's one of the
highest income inequality countries in
the OECD countries I cannot remember
American from the top of my mouth about
some cares but it's one of the highest
income make all the countries within the
within the OECD so what do you think
moving forward
potentially has the the will happen in
terms of credit and the inequality of
income so I think credit is a great tool
right expansion of credit was important
part of progressive agenda in the post
Second World War period in the United
States and there is good reasons for for
that right enabling people to enjoy the
products and services that the global
economy has taught for making people
homeowners these are all wonderful
things so I don't think it's about the
product but it's about the markets and
and and and the way those markets were
sort of transformed especially in the
2000s death became somewhat problematic
and as I said the 2008 economic crisis
displayed those vulnerabilities in all
they're sort of really sort of nakedness
and there have been some attempts at
reform and so going forward I'm somewhat
optimistic in Turkey have they put more
stringent controls on credit as they
have done in this country after there's
so very simply there have been some laws
and they are now beginning to address
the issue of over indebtedness yes very
good thank you so much for having me
I've enjoyed it thank you
for more information about Professor
cush and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you